Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
INTRODUCING...
NINJA CARDS!
I'M A NINJA.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
DRUMROLL, PLEASE.
[DRUMROLL]
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I'VE BEEN DESIGNING PRODUCTS.
I-I-I KNOW I'M GOOD.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
WHAT IF WE OFFERED YOU
$1 MILLION TO JUST BUY IT OUT?
DON'T MAKE A MISTAKE.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
THIS IS ALL GOOD NEWS.
WHERE'S THE BAD NEWS?
WE MADE 100 UNITS,
AND WE SOLD THEM ALL.
WHAT?
THAT'S SICK.
[RIM SHOT]
[BOTH GROAN]
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS A SHREWD
VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
MY NAME IS RAY.
AND I'M ALVIN.
AND WE ARE FROM
THE EAGLE ROCK NEIGHBORHOOD
IN LOS ANGELES,
CALIFORNIA.
RAY AND I GREW UP
IN THE SAME NEIGHBORHOOD,
NEVER REALLY HUNG OUT
UNTIL I MARRIED MY WIFE,
WHO HAPPENED TO HAVE GONE TO
THE SAME HIGH SCHOOL WITH RAY.
NOW WE'RE CLOSE FRIENDS
AND BUSINESS PARTNERS, TOO.
OH,
THAT LOOKS LIKE FUN.
I CAME UP WITH THE IDEA
FOR THIS BUSINESS
WHILE WORKING AT A TREATMENT
FACILITY FOR CHILDREN,
AND ONE OF THE MORE
DIFFICULT TIMES WAS BATH TIME.
THERE WAS ONE KID
IN PARTICULAR
WHO HAD REFUSED TO BATHE
FOR A FEW DAYS.
HE LET ME KNOW
WHAT THE PROBLEM WAS,
AND THAT'S WHEN I HAD
MY "AHA" MOMENT.
I SPENT YEARS DEVELOPING
AND IMPROVING A PRODUCT,
BUT STILL,
SOMETHING WAS MISSING.
THEN I REALIZED ALVIN
HAD HIS OWN DESIGN COMPANY,
SO I ASKED HIM TO HELP ME
DESIGN THE PRODUCT FURTHER.
THAT LOOKS
REALLY, REALLY GOOD.
WE HAVE A LOT OF INTEREST
FROM MAJOR RETAILERS,
BUT WE CAN'T SCALE FAST ENOUGH
TO GET OUR PRODUCT OUT THERE.
WE NEED THE SHARKS'
EXPERTISE AND CAPITAL
TO TAKE OUR PRODUCT
NATIONWIDE.
Uy:
THIS IS IT FOR US.
RAY'S GIVEN UP HIS JOB,
I'VE TRANSITIONED MY BUSINESS
AND TOTALLY FOCUSED ON
THIS PRODUCT, SO WE'RE ALL IN.
ALL IN.
ALL IN, YEAH.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS RAY PHILLIPS.
AND I'M ALVIN UY.
WE'RE THE FOUNDERS OF SoapSox
FROM EAGLE ROCK, CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE HERE TODAY
SEEKING $260,000
FOR A 10% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS,
MEET SoapSox --
THE NEXT GENERATION
OF WASHCLOTHS FOR KIDS.
SHARKS, AS PARENTS,
MAYBE YOU STRUGGLE WITH THIS --
YOU COME HOME
AFTER A LONG DAY AT WORK,
YOU START THE EVENING ROUTINE
OF HOMEWORK, DINNERTIME,
THEN BATH TIME.
[BOTH GROAN]
BATH TIME.
HOW DO I GET MY KID
TO BATHE
WITHOUT THE SCREAMING
AND CRYING?
[GROANS]
WELL, SHARKS,
WE HAVE THE SOLUTION.
WHAT WE CAME UP WITH IS AN
ADORABLE NEW LINE OF PLUSH TOYS
THAT KIDS CAN TAKE FROM PLAYTIME
TO BATH TIME.
OH, LORD.
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS TAKE
A CUTE AND CUDDLY PLUSH TOY,
TURNED IT
INTO A BATH AID
BY SIMPLY REPLACING
ITS INNER STUFFING
WITH ANTIMICROBIAL SPONGE
AND REPLACING THE OUTER MATERIAL
WITH TERRY CLOTH.
LET ME SHOW YOU
HOW IT WORKS.
SIMPLY TAKE SOAP AND PUT IT
IN TANK THE SHARK'S MOUTH.
[LAUGHTER]
OR UNDER THE SHELL
OF TAYLOR THE TURTLE.
SIMPLY ADD WATER...
...USE THE UNIQUELY
DESIGNED FINGER POCKETS
FOR BETTER HANDLING,
WORK INTO A LATHER...
AND LET BATH TIME BEGIN.
AND AFTER BATH TIME...
...SIMPLY HANG SoapSox
TO DRY
OR JUST TOSS IT
INTO THE LAUNDRY.
SO, SHARKS,
WHY DON'T YOU LET US
THROW SOME SoapSox
INTO YOUR TANK
AND YOU THROW SOME CASH
INTO OURS?
SO, WE'RE GONNA HAND OUT SAMPLES
TO YOU NOW.
WE HAVE SEVEN
DIFFERENT CHARACTERS
THAT WE LAUNCHED WITH.
UM...
[CHUCKLES]
MR. HERJAVEC,
WE STARTED WITH YOU
WITH THE WONDERFUL HIPPO,
UH, BECAUSE --
I GET THE PINK HIPPO?
[GREINER CHUCKLES]
YOU GET THE PINK HIPPO
BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW,
HIPPOS ARE NICE AND CUDDLY
AND THEY LOOK THE PART,
BUT THEY'RE THE MOST DANGEROUS
ANIMALS OUT THERE IN THE WORLD.
THANK YOU. YEAH.
OH, YOU KNOW
HOW TO FLATTER.
YEAH.
WHAT'S THE TURTLE?
OKAY,
THIS IS OUR BEST-SELLING TURTLE,
AND WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
YOU HAD THAT.
MR. WONDERFUL, YOU'RE KIND OF
KNOWN TO SPIT SOME FIRE,
SO WE FIGURED WE'D COMPLIMENT
YOU WITH OUR WONDERFUL DRAGON.
IT'S THE DRAGON OF TRUTH.
DAYMOND, YOU'RE MORE OF A, LIKE,
SIT-AND-WAIT KIND OF GUY
FOR THE PERFECT OPPORTUNITY
TO GET YOUR DEALS,
SO WE FIGURED
IT'D BE APPROPRIATE
TO GIVE YOU THE GATOR.
I LIKE THESE GUYS.
UH, MARK,
UH, THAT'S THE BIG SHARK.
THAT'S TANK THE SHARK.
HE'S THE BIGGEST SHARK OF THEM
ALL, SO WE WANTED TO MAKE --
OH, PLEASE!
John: OH, WHATEVER.
[GROWLS]
YOU SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN
A DONKEY FOR MARK.
OH!
WHAT'S YOUR HISTORY
IN BUSINESS
TO COME UP WITH THIS IDEA?
SO, I WORKED AT A RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITY
FOR ABUSED KIDS
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS,
AND ONE OF THE MORE DIFFICULT
TIMES WAS BATH TIME.
WE HAD ONE KID IN PARTICULAR
WHO HAD REFUSED TO BATHE,
AND WE WAS CARRYING
A LITTLE STUFFED ANIMAL.
AND HE WAS LIKE,
"THAT MEAN LADY
"WON'T LET ME
TAKE MY STUFFED ANIMAL
INTO THE BATHTUB WITH ME."
AND SO I SAID, "WE CAN --
WE CAN FIX THAT. HOLD ON."
AND I THOUGHT
OUTSIDE OF THE BOX,
I HAD THE STAFF GRAB
ANOTHER STUFFED ANIMAL,
MADE IT HOLD SOAP,
LATHERED IT UP,
AND HE WAS LIKE,
"OKAY, I'LL GO."
AND SO, AFTER THAT,
THEN THEY'RE LIKE,
"HEY,
MAYBE YOU SHOULD GO FOR IT."
AND SO THEN,
I PARTNERED WITH ALVIN,
WHO HAS A BACKGROUND IN DESIGN
AND PRODUCT DESIGN,
AND HE MADE THE MAGIC
HAPPEN.
GIVE US A SALES PROFILE
AND WHICH RETAILERS YOU'RE IN.
THIS IS A RETAIL-ORIENTED
PRODUCT.
SO, WE'VE BEEN ON THE MARKET
FOR SIX MONTHS,
WE'VE DONE $300,000
IN SALES.
SOME OF THE MAJOR RETAILERS
IS NORDSTROM'S.
THEY'RE GONNA BE ROLLING US OUT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I'M GUESSING THAT YOU HAVE
A PATENT PENDING ON THIS.
SO, WE HAVE
OUR DESIGN PATENT PENDING
AND OUR UTILITY PATENT
PENDING.
AND WHAT DO THEY
RETAIL FOR?
WE ARE RETAILING THEM
FOR $19.95.
WHAT DO THEY COST YOU
TO MAKE?
UH, THEY COST $3.66
CURRENTLY.
RAY, TELL ME ABOUT THE FORECAST
FOR THIS YEAR AND NEXT YEAR.
WE'RE ON TRACK
TO DO $576,000
FOR THE REMAINDER
OF THIS YEAR.
NEXT YEAR, WE ARE ESTIMATED
TO DO $2.4 MILLION.
O'Leary:
LET ME ASK YOU SOMETHING.
YES.
20 BUCKS FOR A SPONGE...
YEAH.
...IS A LOT OF MONEY...
I AGREE.
...'CAUSE EVERY OTHER PLUSH TOY
IN THE STORE
THAT LOOKS LIKE THIS
IS $4.99, $5.99.
THIS IS A REALLY PREMIUM
PLUSH TOY...
YES.
...LIKE, THE FIRST IN MY LIFE
I'VE EVER SEEN FOR $20.
I THINK YOU GUYS GOT
A NICE BUSINESS.
YOU'RE KILLING IT
ON MARGINS.
BUT IT'S NOT A BUSINESS
THAT GETS ME LATHERED UP.
UM, I DON'T KNOW
THAT I COULD HELP,
SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
[GROANS]
Herjavec:
OH, GOSH.
THE -- THE WHOLE THOUGHT
OF MARK LATHERED UP JUST -- UGH.
YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE WOULD PAY FOR THAT.
Greiner:
I HAVE A QUESTION.
INSTEAD OF GOING OUT THERE
WITH NORDSTROM
AND PUTTING IT OUT
AT $19.99,
CAN YOU GO BACK
TO YOUR MANUFACTURERS
AND SEE IF THERE'S ANY WAY
YOU CAN GET THE PRICE DOWN
AND THEN NOT TAKE
SUCH A HEFTY MARGIN?
YOU HAVE
A REALLY HEFTY MARGIN.
RAY, LORI DOES HAVE
A VALID POINT.
WHAT IS THE LOWEST
YOU CAN MAKE IT AT?
TWO --
WE CAN GET IT DOWN TO --
WE THINK WE CAN GET IT DOWN
TO $2.50, $2.70.
FOR YOU TO GET IT DOWN
TO $2.50,
WHAT IS THE QUANTITY
YOU HAVE TO BUY IN?
600,000 UNITS OR MORE.
WOW.
O'Leary: GUYS,
THE PRICE IS TOO HIGH.
I CAN'T EVEN SEE THIS EVER
LONG-TERM MORE THAN $12.99,
EVER.
IT SHOULD BE $9.99.
AND YOU'RE NOT WORTH
$2.6 MILLION.
I'M OUT.
I THINK WHAT YOU'VE PROVEN IS,
YOU HAVE A GREAT CONCEPT.
BUT AT A $2.6 MILLION
VALUE,
FOR ME TODAY
TO GIVE YOU $260,000,
I DON'T THINK
YOU'VE QUITE PROVEN
THAT MY MONEY
WANTS TO GO THERE.
I'M AFRAID
I'LL TAKE A BATH.
THANK YOU.
I'M OUT.
SO, GUYS, WHY ARE YOU VALUING IT
AT $2.6 MILLION?
UH, WE ARE ON SCHEDULE
TO HIT THE $5--
JUST UNDER $600,000
BY THE END OF THE YEAR AND --
ON SCHEDULE 'CAUSE YOU HAVE
EXISTING ORDERS
THAT WILL TAKE YOU THERE?
YES.
OKAY.
SO, I WANT TO BE
PART OF THIS,
BUT I CAN'T GIVE YOU A VALUATION
OF $2.6 MILLION.
I'LL GIVE YOU $260,000
FOR 33%.
THAT'S MY OFFER.
UH, IF YOU DON'T MIND,
I'D LIKE TO HEAR, IF LORI --
I'M FINE WITH THIS,
SO LET'S MOVE IT ALONG.
SOMETHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
I THINK IT'S REALLY
A SMART PRODUCT.
GREAT JOB.
REALLY CLEAR WHAT IT IS,
THE NAME IS FANTASTIC --
SoapSox.
THEN I HAVE THE OTHER SIDE
OF ME THAT'S SAYING,
YOU HAVE A PATENT PENDING,
BUT I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'RE GONNA GET IT.
AND IN THE TIME THAT IT'LL TAKE
FOR YOU TO GET IT,
IT MIGHT BE TWO YEARS,
THREE YEARS,
AND SOMEONE ELSE
MAY COPY IT.
IF YOU WERE AT A LOWER PRICE,
YOU COULD BLITZ THE MARKET.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
SO, COULD YOU RESTATE
YOUR OFFER, DAYMOND,
JUST SO
THAT WE'RE CLEAR?
YEAH, MY OFFER IS $260,000
FOR 33%,
TO MAKE US EQUAL PARTNERS,
THE THREE MUSKETEERS.
WE DON'T MIND
DOING THE HARD WORK.
THAT PERCENTAGE IS HIGHER THAN
WHAT WE'D WANT TO GIVE AWAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO...COUNTE--
DON'T MAKE A MISTAKE.
JUST IN CASE --
JUST THINK ABOUT THIS,
ALL RIGHT?
IF YOU'RE WRONG
ON THE PRICING --
IN OTHER WORDS, IF THE MARKET
THAT REALLY CLEARS IS $9.99,
WHICH I THINK IT IS,
YOU'RE REALLY GONNA NEED
THIS GUY
BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA GO OUT
WITH A MISSTEPPED LAUNCH,
THE FIRST RETAILERS
THAT YOU PUT THE SKUs INTO
ARE GONNA HAVE SLOW SALES
AND DELIST YOU,
AND THEN
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO RETRACE
AND FIGURE OUT HOW
TO GET THE MANUFACTURING COST
DOWN TO ABOUT A BUCK 35.
ON YOUR OWN,
THAT'S GONNA BE HARD,
AND SO IF HE'S WILLING TO DO IT,
I MEAN, IF YOU WALK OUT OF HERE
WITHOUT THAT DEAL,
YOU'RE MAKING A BIG MISTAKE.
Narrator:
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
ALVIN AND RAY
ARE SEEKING $260,000
FOR 10% OF THEIR CHILDREN'S
BATH TOY COMPANY, SoapSox.
DAYMOND HAS OFFERED
THE AMOUNT THEY ARE SEEKING,
BUT HE WANTS 33% OF THE COMPANY.
IF YOU WALK OUT OF HERE
WITHOUT THAT DEAL,
YOU'RE MAKING A BIG MISTAKE.
SUCK IT UP, TAKE THE PAIN.
YOU ASKED FOR TOO MUCH
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
[CUBAN CHUCKLES]
ALL RIGHT?
YOU ASKED FOR TOO MUCH.
YOU WANTED $260,000, AND THOSE
ARE THE RULES OF "SHARK TANK" --
HE'S GOT TO GIVE YOU $260,000.
YOU'VE GOT TO PAY
FOR THAT MISTAKE.
YOU'RE PAYING FOR IT RIGHT NOW.
UM...
TH-- THE 33% IS --
IS STEEP, UH, FOR US
AND -- AND WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING.
WE KNOW YOU BRING
A LOT OF VALUE.
UH, YOU WERE
ONE OF THE SHARKS
THAT WE WERE HOPING TO BE ABLE
TO GET A DEAL WITH,
AND I'M HOPING WE CAN STILL
COME TO AGREEMENT
ON WHERE THAT NUMBER
REALLY LIES.
UM, WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO DO...15%...FOR...
...$350,000?
OOH,
THEY ARE PROUD.
WOW.
MM-HMM.
I SHOULD WASH HIS MOUTH OUT
WITH SOAP
FOR THAT COUNTER.
HOLD ON.
YEAH. SO, GUYS...
...I'M GONNA HAVE TO STAY FIRM
ON THE 33%.
Greiner:
I HAVE A QUESTION.
YES.
Herjavec:
LORI AND I HAVE BEEN TALKING.
WHAT IF WE OFFERED YOU
$1 MILLION TO JUST BUY IT OUT?
WE [CHUCKLES]
WE AREN'T AFRAID
OF THE HARD WORK
AND BUILDING IT
TO SOMETHING BIGGER.
Uy: FOR US,
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE MONEY.
I'VE BEEN DESIGNING PRODUCTS
FOR BIGGER COMPANIES.
I-I KNOW I'M GOOD.
BUT THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
WHERE I FEEL LIKE,
"YOU KNOW WHAT? I'M FINALLY
DOING SOMETHING FOR MYSELF."
YEAH.
WE OWN THIS.
WE'RE DREAM CHASERS
RIGHT NOW,
SO WE DON'T WANT
TO GIVE IT AWAY.
WE WANT A PARTNERSHIP,
BUT WE'RE DREAM CHASERS.
WE'RE CHASING
AFTER THE AMERICAN DREAM.
AND...YEAH.
Greiner: YOU KNOW WHAT?
I GET THAT.
RAY, LORI AND I SAW
A LOT OF VALUE IN THE PRODUCT,
BUT I THINK...
HER AND I SEE
A POTENTIALLY DIFFERENT PATH.
SO, WE JUST THOUGHT,
WE'RE WILLING TO RISK $1 MILLION
TO TRY TO TAKE IT
DOWN THE PATH.
Greiner: YOU'RE INNOVATORS,
SO THIS, I DON'T THINK,
IS GOING TO BE
YOUR LAST PRODUCT.
Phillips: YEAH.
IT'S GOING TO BE
THE FIRST OF MANY.
O'Leary: GUYS, YOU GOT --
YOU GOT TO MAKE A DECISION.
YOU GOT A $1 MILLION OFFER,
OR YOU CAN PARTNER
WITH DAYMOND.
YOU GOT TO GIVE UP
A THIRD OF THE COMPANY.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DECLINE
BOTH OFFERS.
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
John: GOODBYE.
GOODBYE.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
Phillips: THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK.
LITTLE DISAPPOINTED
THAT THEY DEVALUATED OUR PRODUCT
THAT MUCH.
Phillips: I DON'T THINK EVEN
IF THEY'D OFFERED US $5 MILLION
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TAKEN IT,
OR $10 MILLION,
BECAUSE IT'S SO MUCH MORE
THAN THAT.
Narrator:
IN SEASON 3, FLEETWOOD HICKS
MADE A DEAL
WITH MARK AND BARBARA
FOR HIS CUSTOM BICYCLE COMPANY,
VILLY CUSTOMS.
I THINK YOU GUYS GOT
AN INCREDIBLE DEAL.
THAT'S THE ONLY KIND
OF DEALS WE DO.
Corcoran: AND A FUN DEAL,
AS WELL.
WOW.
Narrator:
LET'S SEE WHAT HE'S UP TO NOW.
Hicks: LET'S WHIP IT INTO SHAPE,
MAN. WE GOT A LOT TO DO.
COME ON, DeVILLE.
BEING ON "SHARK TANK"
IMMEDIATELY LEGITIMIZED
OUR BUSINESS.
GOOD JOB.
BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
OUR TOTAL SALES WERE $248,000.
SINCE BEING ON "SHARK TANK,"
WE HAVE 10,000 SQUARE FEET
OF SPACE,
AND WE'RE GONNA SURPASS
$2 MILLION IN SALES.
IT'S THE DETAILS, MAN.
IT'S THE DETAILS. YOU KNOW THAT.
WE'VE REALLY BEEN FOCUSING
ON OUR CORPORATE BIKE PROGRAM.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH SOME HUGE BRANDS --
PepsiCo, MONSTER ENERGY.
WE'VE ALSO MADE BIKES
FOR THE BAND OneRepublic
AND EVEN STEVEN TYLER
OF AEROSMITH.
OO-HOO!
OH, HEY, BARB.
HOW YOU DOING?
GOOD. I'M IN DALLAS
FOR A MEETING.
I HAD TO STOP BY.
AH.
WORKING WITH BARBARA AND MARK
HAS BEEN AN AWESOME EXPERIENCE.
BARBARA'S A MARKETING EXPERT,
AND SHE'S AN INCREDIBLE
ROLE MODEL.
WOW.
THIS HAS
YOUR NAME ON IT, BARB.
I AM BLOWN AWAY AT WHAT
FLEETWOOD HAS BUILT HERE.
LAST TIME I WAS HERE, THIS SPACE
WAS ONE THIRD THE SIZE,
WE WERE DOING
1/3 THE BIKE SALES,
AND THAT WAS ONLY A YEAR AGO.
OKAY, ENOUGH OF THIS.
LET'S GO ON A BIKE RIDE.
COME ON.
LET'S DO IT.
Hicks: I CAN HONESTLY SAY
"SHARK TANK" HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE MOST INCREDIBLE
ADVENTURES OF MY LIFE.
MARK AND BARBARA SAW
THE POTENTIAL IN VILLY CUSTOMS.
NOW I GET TO DO WHAT I LOVE
EVERY DAY.
[ALL CHEER]
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A PRODUCT DESIGNED TO CARRY
ONE'S MOST VALUABLE POSSESSIONS.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ANASTASIA BALYURA.
I AM SEEKING $25,000
FOR 10% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
MY BABY TRIXIE
LOVES TO BE HELD 24/7.
TRIXIE EVEN ATTENDED LAW SCHOOL
WITH ME.
IN FACT,
TRIXIE IS HERE WITH ME NOW.
Herjavec: OH!
[CHUCKLES]
[LAUGHS]
MY BUSINESS IS HEART PUP.
IT IS THE WORLD'S BEST
DOG CARRIER.
[CHUCKLES]
[GREINER CHUCKLES]
HEART PUP DOG CARRIERS
ARE UNLIKE ANY OTHER
BECAUSE MINE ARE FUNCTIONAL,
FASHIONABLE, AND COMFORTABLE.
MY SLINGS ARE HANDMADE
OUT OF AN ITALIAN
CASHMERE-WOOL BLEND.
THEY FEEL SO LUXURIOUS.
THE LARGE OUTSIDE POCKET
LETS YOU BRING YOUR PHONE,
WALLET, KEYS.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY LEAVE
YOUR PURSE AT HOME.
THE ERGONOMIC DESIGN
GOES ON BOTH SHOULDERS
FOR A SUPER SNUG
AND COMFORTABLE WEAR.
SO CUTE.
THE CLIP ATTACHED INSIDE
GOES ON THE PUPPY'S HARNESS
OR COLLAR
SO THAT IF YOUR PUPPY'S A JUMPER
OR YOU JUST WANT TO BE ABLE
TO BEND OVER, RIGHT?
[Chuckling]
"PUPPY'S A JUMPER."
YOUR PUP WILL DEFINITELY
HEART THIS, RIGHT, TRIXIE?
"I HEART IT."
AW.
THANK YOU.
[CHUCKLES]
I ACTUALLY HAVE
SOME CUSTOM-MADE SAMPLES
I'D LOVE TO PASS OUT TO YOU.
SURE.
CAN I JUST ASK YOU --
IS TRIXIE DRUGGED?
[CHUCKLES]
SHE'S THE BEST-BEHAVED DOG.
THAT ONE'S FOR YOU.
CAN I SEE HER?
OH, SURE.
ANASTASIA,
I HAVE A CHIHUAHUA,
Balyura: LORI, THIS IS
GONNA LOOK AWESOME ON YOU.
NOT A LONG-HAIRED ONE.
EXACT SAME COLORS.
30% OF CUSTOMERS ARE MEN.
YOU LOVE THIS, YEAH.
John: REALLY?
IT-- IT'S MY DAUGHTERS'.
LET'S JUST GET THAT STRAIGHT
RIGHT NOW.
OH, GREAT, GREAT.
WELL, YOUR DAUGHTER WOULD LOOK
SO AMAZING IN THIS.
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT.
Greiner: SO, HAVE YOU
BEEN SELLING THESE?
I HAVE, YES.
I ACTUALLY AM A BIT
OF AN ENTREPRENEUR ON ACCIDENT
[CHUCKLES] UM, BECAUSE I WAS IN
MY FINAL SEMESTER OF LAW SCHOOL,
AND THOSE LAW BOOKS,
THEY'RE HUGE.
SO, IT WAS KIND OF TOUGH
TO HOLD HER AND THE BOOKS.
AND SHE LOVES TO BE HELD.
YOU BROUGHT TRIXIE
THROUGH AN HOUR AND A HALF?
TO LAW SCHOOL.
OH, YEAH. OH, YEAH.
AND TRIXIE LOVES TO BE HELD.
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO BE ZIPPED UP
OFF TO THE SIDE
IN SOME BAG
THAT'S FALLING OFF MY SHOULDER.
ARE YOU A LAWYER NOW?
UM, ACTUALLY,
I STARTED THIS COMPANY
MY LAST SEMESTER OF LAW SCHOOL,
AND WHEN I INVENTED THIS,
I STARTED BRINGING HER
TO LAW SCHOOL LIKE THIS.
AND MY PATENT LAW PROFESSOR
SAID,
"THE LAWS ARE CHANGING
AT THE END OF THIS MONTH,
"SO IF YOU POST THIS ONLINE
RIGHT NOW,
YOU'LL ACTUALLY HAVE
COMMON-LAW PATENT PROTECTION."
YEAH, SO HOW LONG
HAVE YOU BEEN SELLING IT,
AND HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD
THIS YEAR?
YEAH, UM, SO I STARTED, UH,
IN JULY OF 2013,
SO I'VE BEEN
FOR ALMOST A YEAR NOW.
AND, UH, I HAVE SOLD, UH,
ABOUT 980 UNITS, UH --
AT WHAT PRICE?
UH, THEY'RE $138 EACH.
WHAT?!
$138 EACH?
YEAH, BECAUSE
THEY'RE A FASHION ACCESSORY.
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE IT, ANASTASIA?
UM, $8 FOR FABRIC
AND THEN $8 FOR PRODUCTION.
[Chuckling] WOW.
YOUR MARGINS ARE CRAZY.
[JOHN CHUCKLES]
THOSE ARE THE BEST MARGINS
I'VE EVER HEARD.
WELL, YOU KNOW --
ANASTASIA,
WHAT ARE YOUR TOTAL SALES?
UH, MY TOTAL SALES ARE
$135,000.
YOU'RE KILLING IT.
YOU'RE MAKING REAL MONEY.
YEAH.
I MAKE A LITTLE MONEY,
YOU'RE MAKING --
WHERE ARE YOU
SELLING THESE?
YOU'RE MAKING
$100,000 A YEAR.
YEAH, I GUESS SO.
I MEAN, OUR SALES SEEM TO
BE DOUBLING EACH YEAR.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU GUESS SO?
I -- YOU KNOW, FOR ME,
I -- IT'S NOT EVEN
JUST ABOUT THE MONEY.
THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
YEAH, I WANT TO MAKE
A LOT OF MONEY WITH THIS,
BUT MOSTLY,
I WANT TO GO OUT THERE
AND REALLY, YOU KNOW,
PARTNER WITH A STRATEGIC PARTNER
LIKE YOU SHARKS,
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
ALL THE ANSWERS.
TO PARAPHRASE HENRY FORD,
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
TO ANY QUESTION YOU CAN ASK ME,
BUT ANY QUESTION
YOU CAN ASK ME,
THERE'S A ROW OF BUTTONS
ON MY DESK,
AND I CAN PUSH ONE
AND GET SOMEBODY
THAT CAN GIVE YOU THE ANSWER.
AND THAT'S WHY
I NEED YOU, SHARKS.
I NEED YOU TO BE
ONE OF MY BUTTONS
SO THAT I'LL HAVE THE ANSWERS...
[LAUGHS]
LOVE IT.
I LIKE THAT.
...SO THAT I'LL BE ABLE
TO GO FORTH AND --
HOW ARE YOU SELLING THEM?
FOR THE MOST PART,
IT'S THROUGH THE INTERNET
AND JUST WORD OF MOUTH,
BECAUSE --
HOLD ON FOR A SECOND.
ANASTASIA, CAN I SEE THE DOG?
CAN I SEE THE DOG?
YEAH.
O'Leary: I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYBODY MORE RELAXED
IN THE SHARK TANK THAN TRIXIE.
[CHUCKLES]
[LAUGHS]
VERY LAID-BACK.
SHE IS --
OBVIOUSLY, YOU BORED HER
TO DEATH IN LAW SCHOOL.
SHE'S WELL TRAINED.
ANASTASIA,
YOU'RE MAKING THIS YOURSELF?
YES, I AM.
AND SO I'M SURE
THEY'RE NOT PERFECTION, DAYMOND.
NO, I CAN --
I CAN GET OV--
I -- I'M NOT A SEAMSTRESS.
I MEAN, THE SEWING, YES,
YOU CAN TELL
THAT IT'S NOT
A-A COMMERCIAL NEEDLE,
BUT THE FABRIC'S
REALLY NICE.
YEAH.
WHAT DO YOU PLAN TO USE
THE $25,000 FOR?
THE FIRST
AND MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT I WILL DO NO MATTER WHAT
IS GET THE PRODUCTION
OFF MY PLATE
SO I CAN FOCUS
ON RUNNING THE BUSINESS.
UM, SO I WILL GET A FACTORY
TO MAKE THESE.
I'M ACTUALLY STILL
HANDMAKING THESE AT THIS POINT.
Herjavec:
I LOVE ANIMALS.
I MEAN, AS YOU CAN TELL,
YEAH, I KNOW THAT ABOUT YOU.
IT'S GREAT.
AND, UH, YOU KNOW, ONE
OF THE THINGS I-I'VE LEARNED
OVER SIX SEASONS
OF "SHARK TANK" IS
YOU GOT TO GET IN
ON THE RIGHT DEALS,
BUT SOMETIMES, YOU MAY NOT BE
THE RIGHT PARTNER.
SO, I DON'T SEE THIS
AS A WIDE BUSINESS
OR A FASHION ACCESSORY.
WELL, THEY'RE SELLING
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
I DON'T SHARE
IN YOUR VISION,
WHICH IS OKAY.
THAT'S OKAY.
YOU'RE MAKING
$100,000 A YEAR.
SURE.
POWER TO YOU.
KEEP GOING.
YEAH.
AS AN INVESTOR, THOUGH,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
Cuban:
ANASTASIA, I TOTALLY SEE
HOW THIS COULD BE AN AMAZING
BUSINESS, ALL RIGHT, BUT --
YES, WITH HUGE MARGINS.
WITH HUGE MARGINS.
WITH FORWARD THINKING,
WITH SETTING A TREND.
BUT IT WOULD
DRIVE ME CRAZY...
[CHUCKLES]
...JUST TRYING TO DEAL
WITH ALL OF IT.
IT REALLY WOULD.
BUT --
BUT WHAT WOULD YOU
BE DEALING WITH?
JUST LIKE YOU SAID,
YOU NEED A PARTNER
TO BE A BUTTON, RIGHT?
I DON'T MAKE A GOOD BUTTON.
I'M NOT BUTTON MATERIAL.
YOU KNOW, MAYBE
I DIDN'T SAY THAT RIGHT...
[CHUCKLES]
...BECAUSE ALL I NEED
IS A PARTNER
THAT CAN EITHER PUT ME
IN TOUCH WITH SOMETHING
OR TELL ME, "HERE'S --"
I WOULD GO NUTS, TRIXIE.
THAT'S -- I MEAN ANASTASIA.
[LAUGHTER]
NO, MARK. MARK. MARK, NO.
ACTUALLY, MARK, WHAT I WOULD BE
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT IS TH--
ME AND THE BUTTON ARE NOT ONE,
SO I'VE -- I'VE GOT TO GO OUT.
OKAY, MARK, CAN I ASK
WHY SPECIFICALLY
OR WHAT SPECIFICALLY YOU THINK
MIGHT BE A CONCERN?
MAN, ANASTASIA,
YOU CAN TALK.
MAYBE I CAN ADDRESS IT.
[CHUCKLES]
BRUTALLY HONEST,
I'D GO NUTS.
OKAY, MARK,
JUST TO ADDRESS YOUR POINTS --
GO THAT WAY. DO-- DON'T. PLEASE,
PLEASE, PLEASE, PLEASE, PLEASE.
CAN I JUST RESPOND, THOUGH,
TO YOUR POINTS VERY BRIEFLY?
[LAUGHTER]
NO.
NO, YOU'RE -- SEE?
ANASTASIA, HE'S OUT.
DO YOU SEE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING?
YOU GOT TO GO ON.
DO YOU SEE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE, ANASTASIA?
ANASTASIA,
YOU STILL HAVE THREE SHARKS
THAT ARE
POTENTIAL INVESTORS.
YEAH, NO PROBLEM.
YEAH.
GO AFTER LORI.
[CHUCKLES]
SHE'S DYING
TO COME BACK.
I'M WILLING TO TALK
TO THE OTHER SHARKS --
MORE THAN HAPPY TO.
SO, LORI...
LORI.
...LET'S MAKE A DEAL.
YOU KNOW, UM, I THINK
THAT YOU SOLD QUITE A LOT
IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
OF SOMETHING THAT'S VERY NICHE
AND UNUSUAL, YOU KNOW?
YEAH.
MY FEAR IS
IS THAT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S EASY FOR PEOPLE
TO REPLICATE QUICKLY.
I LIKE THINGS THAT ARE UNIQUE,
THAT HAVE BROAD MASS APPEAL.
YEAH.
THIS IS RATHER NICHE.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
UM, LORI,
I ACTUALLY HAVE --
OKAY, ANASTASIA,
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $25K FOR 50%,
BUT THE DOG BITES IT.
[LAUGHS]
[GREINER CHUCKLES]
I HATE RAT DOGS A LOT.
I JUST HATE THEM.
I DON'T GET IT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY ANYBODY
WOULD WANT A RAT AS A PET.
HOW CAN YOU NOT
GET THIS?
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
COME ON, DAYMOND.
John: WELL, I'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR THIS MOMENT,
NOW THAT WE'VE GOT ALL THE
JOKERS OUT OF THE DECK HERE.
[CHUCKLES]
UM, I WOULD HAVE NEVER EXPECTED
TO GET EDUCATED
IN THE PET DEPARTMENT
IN THE LAST YEAR.
MY DIRECTOR OF LICENSING
JUST RUNS IN MY OFFICE AND SAYS,
"WE'RE REPRESENTING TARA THE CAT
WHETHER YOU LIKE IT OR NOT."
AND I GO ON YOUTUBE,
I SEE TARA THE CAT.
SHE GOES AND SAVES A CHILD
FROM BEING MAULED BY A DOG.
I SAW THAT.
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
RIGHT?
SO, I'VE GOTTEN
A QUICK EDUCATION IN THIS AREA,
AND THERE'S MONEY
TO BE MADE.
ABSOLUTELY.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
REALLY?
GREAT.
I'LL GIVE YOU $50,000
FOR 40%.
[CHUCKLES]
THAT'S SICK.
DAYMOND, YOU GOT A DEAL.
WOW.
EASY BREEZY. THAT'S BEING
PRECISE. I LIKE THAT.
SHORT AND SWEET.
THANK YOU.
HECK, YEAH.
I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
CONGRATS.
Herjavec:
WAY TO GO, TRIXIE.
CONGRATULATIONS,
ANASTASIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OH, YEAH,
I FORGOT THE DOG.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
CONGRATS. BYE.
SEE YA.
I'LL GIVE YOU 50 BUCKS
FOR TRIXIE.
[CHUCKLES]
YAY! WE GOT A DEAL!
TRIXIE, YOU EXCITED?
WE GET TO GO WORK.
GO TO WORK!
I KNOW I'M AN INNOVATOR,
AND IT'S A LITTLE SAD
THAT THE OTHER SHARKS
DIDN'T GET IT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THAT'S OKAY.
I FEEL LIKE OFTENTIMES,
I AM A LITTLE BIT LIKE
EINSTEIN'S FAMOUS QUOTE
WHERE HE HAS TO ALWAYS ASK
HIMSELF, "AM I INSANE,
OR IS THE REST OF THE WORLD?"
Narrator:
NEXT UP ARE ENTREPRENEURS
WHO BELIEVE THEY HAVE THE NEXT
BIG HIT IN THE TOY INDUSTRY.
[CHUCKLES]
OOH.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS DUSTIN,
A.K.A. "THE RED DRAGON."
AND I'M KEN.
THEY CALL ME "THE BUTCHER."
WE'RE HERE
LOOKING FOR $60,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR
30% OF OUR COMPANY.
SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE 15th CENTURY,
MANKIND
HAS BEEN FASCINATED
BY THE MYSTERIOUS WAYS
OF THE NINJA.
HA!
A NINJA IS CUNNING.
A NINJA IS WISE.
A NINJA CAN ADAPT TO THEIR
SURROUNDINGS SEAMLESSLY,
OFTEN MAKING THEMSELVES
INVISIBLE TO THEIR ENEMIES.
NINJAS FOLLOW
A MORAL CODE
REGARDING DIGNITY, HONOR,
AND RESPECT.
[CHUCKLES]
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS
THAT EVERYONE WANTS
TO BE A NINJA,
AND NOW,
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER,
WE CAN ALL FINALLY BE NINJAS
IN OUR OWN RIGHT.
INTRODUCING...
NINJA CARDS!
Herjavec: NO.
Greiner: PRETTY COOL.
OH, MY GOSH.
THAT IS SO COOL.
THAT IS GREAT.
ESSENTIALLY, OUR GAME
IS LIKE DARTS BUT WITH CARDS.
YOU CAN PLAY GAMES LIKE
AROUND THE WORLD, HORSE, 21.
YOU CAN EVEN MAKE UP
YOUR OWN GAMES.
THE POSSIBILITIES
ARE ENDLESS.
BUT TO TRULY UNDERSTAND
AND APPRECIATE THIS GAME,
YOU HAVE TO PLAY IT.
SO, AT THIS POINT,
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE TWO SHARKS
TO COMPETE
IN A NINJA CARD BATTLE.
OH! OH! OH! OH!
IT'S GOT TO BE ME.
[ALL TALKING EXCITEDLY]
STEP RIGHT UP!
COME ON, GUYS.
YOU'RE GONNA WIN A PRIZE
PLAYING SOME NINJA CARDS.
ALL RIGHT.
THE BUTCHER'S GONNA SHOW YOU
SOME TECHNIQUES.
Haton:
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
O'Leary: OKAY.
SO, THE FIRST TECHNIQUE
IS THE FRISBEE THROW.
VERY SIMPLE.
GO LIKE THAT.
GO FOR US.
SECOND THROW,
LITTLE BIT MORE DIFFICULT,
IS THE TOMAHAWK.
SAME HOLD
AS THE FRISBEE THROW
ONLY YOU'RE GOING
VERTICAL MOTION.
GOT IT.
THE HARDEST TO MASTER,
BUT MY PERSONAL FAVORITE,
IS THE SIDEWINDER,
JUST LIKE THIS.
Berk:
AS AN ADDED INCENTIVE TODAY,
WE MADE A SPECIAL BOARD
FOR YOU GUYS.
OKAY.
LET'S CHECK IT OUT.
READY?
[LAUGHTER]
Berk: OKAY.
Herjavec: KEVIN.
NOW, THE GAME IS, WHOEVER HITS
THE MOST SHARKS WINS.
[LAUGHS]
Haton: THERE IT IS.
Berk: ONE.
WHOO!
YOU DIDN'T HIT --
YOU GOT TO HIT A --
YOU GOT TO FLING IT.
OH!
OH, DOES THAT COUNT?
YEAH,
THAT DIDN'T GET ME.
I THINK THAT COUNTS.
Berk: ANYWHERE
ON THE SHARK COUNTS.
FLING IT. FLING IT.
YOU GOT TO FLING IT
IN THERE. OH!
OH, THERE IT IS.
OH, I GOT CUBAN.
THERE IT IS.
WINGED. YOU WINGED ME.
THAT DOESN'T COUNT.
FLING IT.
YEAH, FLING IT.
[GROANS]
OOH. OH, THAT COUNTS.
THAT COUNTS.
OH.
OH, THAT --
THERE WE GO.
FLING IT FASTER.
A LITTLE BIT FASTER.
THERE YOU GO.
OH!
DEATH. YES.
OH, WE GOT A NATURAL.
OKAY, GUYS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE A CHAMPION.
Haton: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Herjavec: IT IS KIND OF FUN,
I GOT TO TELL YOU.
Greiner: SO, IS THAT, LIKE,
A REGULAR PLAYING CARD,
OR IS THAT THICKER,
OR...?
Berk: IT'S A NINJA CARD.
IT'S A SPECIAL CARD.
IT'S A NINJA CARD.
BUT IT IS A, UH,
THICK, PLASTIC CARD.
DO YOU HAVE TO BUY, UM,
A SPECIAL BOARD
IN WHICH TO USE WITH IT?
THIS IS THE GAME
THAT YOU BUY AT THE STORE.
OKAY. OKAY.
Herjavec: OH, I SEE.
THAT'S THE PACKAGING.
YEP. FOR NOW.
SO, IT'S --
IT'S A THICK STYROFOAM.
CORRECT.
Herjavec:
HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD?
WE SOLD -- WE MADE 100 UNITS,
AND WE SOLD THEM ALL.
A WHOLE 100 UNITS?
[CHUCKLES]
A WHOLE 100 UNITS.
WOW.
OVER WHAT PERIOD
OF TIME?
[LAUGHTER]
OUR SALES ARE
WHAT MR. WONDERFUL WOULD CALL
POO-POO.
YEAH.
BUT THAT'S BECAUSE
WE LAUNCHED IN JULY 2012,
AND THEN WE SIGNED
AN EXCLUSIVE LICENSE AGREEMENT.
YES.
John: OH!
Cuban: TELL US MORE!
GRASSHOPPER,
TELL ME MORE.
John: OH!
Berk: YEAH, SO WE WENT
TO THE TOY SHOW,
AND IT HAPPENED TO BE
THE CHICAGO TOY FAIR.
AND WITHIN
THE FIRST HOUR,
WE GOT OFFERED
A LICENSE AGREEMENT.
THE DEAL WAS AN EXCLUSIVE,
SO THEY HAD THE WHOLE THING.
AND IT WAS 5%,
ESCALATED 1% PER YEAR.
OKAY, THIS IS ALL GOOD NEWS.
WHERE'S THE BAD NEWS?
THAT'S THE BAD NEWS.
THE BAD NEWS IS, THEY COULDN'T
SOURCE IT IN CHINA
SO THEY BAILED OUT
AFTER A YEAR.
WHAT?
Herjavec:
THEY COULDN'T SOURCE WHAT?
HOW COULD THEY NOT
SOURCE THIS?
IT'S STYROFOAM!
IT'S NOT EXACTLY
STYROFOAM.
WHAT IS IT?
IT'S A --
IT'S A SPECIAL CRAFT FOAM.
DID YOU GET OUT OF THAT?
YES. YES.
YEAH, IT ENDED, UH --
THE RIGHTS
REVERTED BACK TO YOU?
THE RIGHTS REVERTED BACK TO US.
WE OWN 100%.
WE HAVE EVERYTHING BACK.
HOW LONG AGO
DID THEY REVERT BACK?
END OF --
IT WAS LAST YEAR.
SO, WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN DOING
ALL THIS TIME?
I'VE BEEN ON THE PHONE
TRYING TO GET OUR PRICES DOWN,
LOOKING FOR INVESTORS.
DID YOU GO
TO OTHER TOY COMPANIES
AND TRY TO DO
ANOTHER LICENSING DEAL?
NOT SINCE THEN, NO.
'CAUSE, UH,
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW ANY.
"WE DON'T KNOW ANY"?
Cuban: YOU GUYS THOUGHT
YOU HAD IT EASY, RIGHT?
YOU WERE AN HOUR INTO
THE BUSINESS, AND YOU WERE SET.
WE WERE TOLD TO SIT BACK
AND ENJOY THE RIDE.
YEAH.
AND YOU CERTAINLY --
NO, BUT HERE'S
THE PROBLEM --
YOU GOT A RIDE.
THAT'S FOR DANG SURE.
YOU GOT RUN OVER.
IF YOU GUYS HAD ORDERS
AND YOU DID THE TOY SHOW,
YOU NOW HAVE CONTACTS, RIGHT?
Berk: CORRECT. YES.
I'M SURE YOU TOOK A CARD
FROM EVERY SINGLE PERSON
THAT WAS INTERESTED...
ABSOLUTELY.
...ESPECIALLY RETAIL STORES.
SO, WHY DON'T YOU JUST GO BACK?
WE DO.
WE HAVE A LOT OF --
IT FALLS APART, YOU CALL THEM,
YOU SAY, "HEY, I'M A FREE AGENT.
I WANT TO SELL TO YOU."
THE PRODUCT
NEVER REACHED PRODUCTION.
GUYS, LOOK, I'M WILLING TO BE
A DISCIPLE OF THE NINJA WAY,
BUT I JUST DON'T SEE IT
AS A FIT FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
THE NINJA WOULD DO ANYTHING,
INCLUDING LAY HIS LIFE DOWN,
IN THE SERVICE
OF A GREATER GOOD.
YOU CAN'T EVEN
PICK UP A PHONE
AND MAKE A CALL
TO ANOTHER TOY COMPANY.
I'M NOT SEEING
ENOUGH HUSTLE.
I'M OUT.
WE NEED THE POWER OF SOMEONE
TO MAKE A PHONE CALL
TO HELP US CUT OUT
OUR MIDDLE MAN.
WE CAN'T GO
STRAIGHT TO...
THEY WON'T EVEN ANSWER
MY PHONE CALL.
OKAY.
I THINK IT'S CLEVER.
I THINK KIDS WILL LOVE IT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND, THOUGH --
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO HUSTLE,
YOU HAVE TO BE
AT LEAST THAT ENTERPRISING
IN WHICH TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT TO DO
AFTER A DISTRIBUTOR
LEAVES YOU IN THE LURCH.
SO, FOR THAT REASON,
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T DO ANYTHING,
I'M OUT.
WE'VE SEEN MANY,
MANY COMPANIES LIKE THIS.
I HAVE MANY FRIENDS
THAT HAVE GOTTEN
FINANCIALLY BUTCHERED
IN THE TOYS INDUSTRY.
I DON'T THINK
I'LL EVER SEE MY MONEY BACK.
I CAN'T TAKE THAT CHANCE
AND FALL ON THE SWORD WITH YOU,
SO I'M OUT.
O'Leary: NINJAS,
THANK GOODNESS YOU'VE MET ME.
I, TOO, AM A NINJA --
SENSEI WONDERFUL, YOUR MASTER.
NOW, HERE'S WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO DO --
I THINK YOU SHOULD TAKE THIS
BEHIND THE DOJO...
[LAUGHTER]
...AND THROW A POISON DART
INTO IT.
WAIT TILL IT DIES,
AND RETURN
WHEN THE TASK IS DONE.
[LAUGHTER]
AND ONE MORE THING --
I'M OUT.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU, SHARKS.
[CUBAN CHUCKLES]
HAI.
NOW WE GOT TO DUCK.
Haton:
THE SHARKS CAME DOWN ON US
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T PICK UP
THE PHONE,
BUT WE JUST DIDN'T FEEL
LIKE OUR PRODUCT
WAS READY
TO GO TO MARKET YET.
AND NOW I THINK THAT, UH,
WE'LL BE READY
TO TAKE IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL
AND GET THIS PRODUCT OUT THERE,
UH, EVEN WITHOUT THEM.
OOH!
NICE!
LOOK AT THAT.
I GOT THE CURVE GOING.
Narrator: NEXT UP IS INNOVATIVE,
NEW WEARABLE TECHNOLOGY.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S TYLER FREEMAN.
AND I'M LEI YU.
AND OUR COMPANY IS DRUMPANTS.
WE'RE OFFERING $150,000 IN
EXCHANGE FOR 5% OF OUR COMPANY.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU
SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR YEARS,
AND WITH THE HELP
OF OUR PHENOMENAL TEAM,
IT'S FINALLY READY.
DRUMROLL, PLEASE.
[DRUMROLL]
[ELECTRONIC DRUM BEATS PLAY]
["SHARK TANK"
THEME SONG PLAYS]
[LAUGHTER]
SO, THIS IS DRUMPANTS,
WHICH,
AS YOU JUST SAW,
LETS YOU PLAY MUSIC
WHEREVER YOU ARE
WITHOUT MISSING A BEAT.
[RIM SHOT]
[LAUGHTER]
DRUMPANTS ARE A WEARABLE
CONTROLLER PLATFORM.
YOU CAN WEAR IT IN ANY CLOTHES,
NOT JUST YOUR PANTS,
AND YOU CAN ALSO USE IT
FOR MORE THAN JUST MUSIC.
YOU CAN CONTROL APPS, GAMES,
UM, AND WEBSITES.
TOGETHER,
WE CAN CHANGE
HOW PEOPLE INTERACT
WITH THEIR DEVICES
AND HELP SHAPE THE FUTURE
OF WEARABLE TECHNOLOGY.
SO, SHARKS, JOIN US.
IT'S TIME TO MARCH TO THE BEAT
OF A DIFFERENT DRUM...PANTS.
[ELECTRONIC NOTE PLAYS]
[LAUGHTER]
John: BA-BAM.
THAT'S PRETTY WILD.
SO, YOU'RE USING WHAT
AS THE INTERFACE,
USING BLUETOOTH BACK TO A PHONE
THAT'S SOMEWHERE, RIGHT?
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE'RE USING BLUETOOTH.
YOU CAN CONNECT
TO ANY DEVICE.
WE HAVE THESE WEARABLE SENSORS.
THEY'RE SOFT.
YOU CAN PUT THEM
IN ANY CLOTHES.
WHAT DO THEY LOOK LIKE,
TYLER?
YEAH,
WE GOT SOME RIGHT HERE.
YOU GUYS WANT
TO SEE THEM?
THEY'RE WORN ON THE BODY,
NOT IN THE --
IT'S NOT IN THE APPAREL.
RIGHT.
Greiner: OH, OKAY.
YOU CAN PUT IT
IN ANY CLOTHES.
OUR BASIC KIT
COMES WITH SIX SENSORS.
THERE'S FOUR DRUM PADS
THAT CAN GO IN YOUR CLOTHES,
AND WE ACTUALLY ALSO HAVE
TWO FOOT PEDALS
THAT GO IN YOUR SHOES
THAT GIVES YOU A KICK DRUM,
HIGH HAT,
EVEN A LOOP PEDAL
SO YOU CAN LOOP BEATS
AND, LIKE, MAKE COMPLETE SONGS
JUST WHEREVER YOU ARE.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
WE'RE TAKING PREORDERS
ON OUR WEBSITE RIGHT NOW.
O'Leary:
OH, SO YOU'RE PRE-REVENUE?
SO...
YES.
WHAT KIND OF DEMAND
ARE YOU GETTING?
HOW MANY UNITS
ARE PREORDERED?
SO, WE LAUNCHED WITH
OUR KICKSTARTER CAMPAIGN.
REACHED
2 "X" OUR GOAL.
WHAT DID YOU RAISE?
$75,000.
John:
AND HOW MUCH PER UNIT?
OUR PRICE POINT STARTS AT $99,
AND IT GOES UP TO $229.
THERE'S NOTHING PROPRIETARY
ABOUT THIS ACTUAL HARDWARE,
AND SO IT'S A BRAND?
HOW MANY UNITS CAN YOU SELL,
HOW MUCH CASH CAN I MAKE?
IS THAT THE RIGHT WAY
TO LOOK AT IT?
WELL, WE DO HAVE, UH,
SEVERAL PROVISIONAL PATENTS
THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING ON
TURNING INTO REAL PATENTS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
IS PATENTABLE?
YEAH.
SO, WHAT WE, UH, ARE PATENTING
IS RHYTHMIC GESTURES,
SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY,
UH --
TAPPING
AND MULTIPLE TAPS
CONTROLLING DIFFERENT ASPECTS
OF YOUR DEVICE.
I'M JUST CURIOUS --
HOW BIG A MARKET
ARE PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO PLAY DRUMS ON THEIR BODY?
WELL, IF YOU SEE, LIKE,
THE ELECTRONIC MUSIC,
UH, YOU KNOW, SCENE
IS REALLY GROWING A LOT,
AND A LOT OF THE MUSICIANS
ARE TRYING TO GET AWAY
FROM JUST SITTING BEHIND
THEIR LAPTOPS.
YOU SEE THEM PLAYING THIS HUGE
CONCERT FOR ALL THESE PEOPLE,
AND IT LOOKS LIKE
THEY'RE CHECKING THEIR E-MAIL.
TO GIVE YOU A $3 MILLION
VALUATION ON DRUMPANTS,
I-I DON'T THINK ANYBODY HERE
WAS GONNA SEE THAT VISION.
SO, WE REALLY NEED
TO UNDERSTAND
W-WHAT IT'S GONNA LOOK LIKE
TOMORROW.
Yu: RIGHT.
O'Leary:
DON'T GIVE ME THE CRAP
ABOUT WHAT THE WORLD'S
GONNA LOOK LIKE IN 10 YEARS.
I WANT TO KNOW
HOW MUCH MONEY I CAN MAKE TODAY.
TO DATE,
WE HAVE SOLD 720 UNITS.
WE ARE FORECASTED TO SELL
AN ADDITIONAL 4,000
BASED ON HOLIDAY SALES.
BASED ON OUR NET PROFIT MARGIN
OF 45%,
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
$220,000 WORTH OF PROFIT
AT THE END
OF THIS YEAR ALONE.
WHEN I LOOK AT A PRODUCT,
I JUST LOOK AT SOME BASIC,
SIMPLE THINGS --
CAN I SELL
MILLIONS OF THESE?
DOES IT HAVE
A BROAD ENOUGH MARKET?
GREAT IDEA, BUT, UM, FOR ME,
IT'S JUST TOO NICHE OF A MARKET.
AND SO,
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
JUST IMAGINE
YOU'RE WATCHING QVC,
YOU SEE A PRODUCT
YOU LIKE,
YOU JUST TAP YOUR PANTS
TO BUY IT RIGHT THERE.
COME ON. THAT IS THE DUMBEST
THING I'VE EVER HEARD.
Yu:
BUT WHAT TYLER'S DESCRIBING
IS OUR NEXT-GENERATION
FUTURE PRODUCT.
WHAT WE'RE SELLING TODAY
THAT GIVES US
OUR $3 MILLION VALUATION
IS DRUMPANTS BY ITSELF.
HOW LARGE
THIS LITTLE NICHE IS --
IS VERTICAL, DON'T KNOW.
SOME OF THE OTHER IDEAS YOU HAD
ARE INTERESTING,
BUT YOU HAVE
TONS OF COMPETITION.
SO, WOULD I PAY
$3 MILLION FOR THIS?
NO.
THAT'S A HUGE STRETCH
UNTIL YOU PROVE IT TO ME.
YOU KNOW, WHAT I LOVE ABOUT ME
IS, I CARE ABOUT THE CASH.
CASH.
[CHUCKLES]
AND I THINK YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A HARD TIME GETTING IT.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
Herjavec: SO, HERE --
HERE'S WHERE I'M AT --
GOT TO BE HONEST,
NOT THAT INTERESTED
IN THE DRUMPANTS.
I'M NOT THINKING
ABOUT THAT MARKET
'CAUSE I'M SO EXCITED
ABOUT THE NEXT MARKET.
IT'S A BIT OF A FLYER
'CAUSE I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
OF THESE YOU'RE GONNA SELL,
BUT I THINK
THERE'S SOMETHING THERE.
I MEAN, I THINK
I CAN HELP YOU WITH THIS.
WE DID ALMOST $4 MILLION
FOR THE ChordBuddy,
AND THAT'S
A VERY LOW-TECH PRODUCT.
UM, I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $150,000
FOR 20%.
BOO-YAH.
RESPECTFULLY,
WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE TO --
TO LISTEN TO WHAT MARK HAS --
IF HE'S...
THAT'S A GOOD --
THAT'S A GOOD OFFER.
WHAT IF MARK
HAS NOTHING TO SAY?
Yu: WELL, THEN...
YOU MAY LOSE THAT.
ARE YOU INTERESTED
IN LICENSING THE TECHNOLOGY?
DEFINITELY.
IF IT'S JUST PURELY
A LICENSING PLAY,
AND I WOULD OFFER YOU
$250,000 FOR 20%.
THE LICENSING DEAL
IS A GREAT DEAL,
BUT YOU'RE ONLY GETTING MONEY
IF THE STUFF SELLS.
Yu: RIGHT.
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY --
John:
NO, NO. OH, NO. INCORRECT.
SO -- SO THEN, MY QUESTION --
SEE, THAT'S A BIG MISTAKE
BECAUSE LICENSES
ARE UP-FRONT CASH
AND GUARANTEED MINIMUMS.
HERE'S THE WAY IT GOES,
ALL RIGHT?
SO, YOU GO TO A -- A PERSON
WHO MAKES THIS TYPE OF PRODUCT.
YOU SAY,
"HEY, WE HAVE THIS DEVICE.
WHAT CAN YOU DO?"
AND THEY GO,
"WE SERVICE ALL THE GLOW STICKS
"FOR THE ENTIRE WORLD.
"WE WANT TO ADD THIS
INTO OUR CATALOGUE.
WE WILL GUARANTEE YOU AT LEAST
$1 MILLION OF SALES AT 10%."
SO, YOU'VE GUARANTEED
AT THAT POINT
THAT YOU'LL GET
$100,000 PER YEAR.
I SEE THIS AS A PROFITABLE
PROOF OF CONCEPT.
IT'S THE BIGGER MARKET
I WANT TO BE IN,
BUT I CANNOT BELIEVE YOU GUYS
GOT TOGETHER AND CAME HERE
TO BE
IN THE GLOW-STICK MARKET.
GUYS,
YOU HAVE TO DECIDE RIGHT NOW.
CAN WE, UH,
CONFER IN THE HALLWAY?
YOU KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS IN "SHARK TANK"
WHEN YOU LEAVE THE TANK --
NASTY, NASTY THINGS.
WHAT IS WRONG?
YOU'VE GOT TWO OFFERS.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION.
Narrator:
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
TYLER AND LEI
HAVE OFFERS ON THE TABLE
FROM BOTH ROBERT AND DAYMOND
FOR THEIR WEARABLE CONTROLLER
DEVICE, DRUMPANTS.
GUYS, YOU HAVE TO DECIDE
RIGHT NOW.
CAN WE, UH,
CONFER IN THE HALLWAY?
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
IN "SHARK TANK"
WHEN YOU LEAVE THE TANK --
NASTY, NASTY THINGS.
WHAT IS WRONG?
YOU'VE GOT TWO OFFERS.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION.
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE.
GO AHEAD. GO AHEAD.
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU.
NASTY THINGS.
WELL,
I LIKE DAYMOND'S OFFER
'CAUSE IT'S MORE MONEY
AND HE'S GONNA HELP US
WITH THE LICENSING.
YEAH,
BUT WE UNDERSTAND IT.
THAT'S NOT GONNA HELP US,
LIKE, DEVELOP
OUR NEXT-GENERATION PRODUCT.
AND --
OKAY, BUT...
LIKE,
DAYMOND'S OFFERING
ALMOST TWICE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
FOR THE SAME PERCENTAGE.
LEI,
I'M GETTING OLD HERE!
LET'S JUST GO.
I REALLY DON'T.
I THINK IT WILL.
HE KNOWS ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT WE WANT TO TALK TO.
[DRUMROLL]
Herjavec:
LET'S GET A DRUMROLL, KEVIN.
Greiner: THEY'RE GONNA SAY,
"I TAKE NO OFFER."
[CHUCKLES]
O'Leary: SO, LET'S JUST
SUMMARIZE WHERE WE'RE AT.
ROBERT HAS OFFERED YOU $150,000
FOR 20%,
LIKES WHERE YOU'RE GOING,
DOESN'T CARE
HOW YOU GET REVENUE.
DAYMOND'S MORE SPECIFIC.
HE'S WILLING TO OFFER
MORE MONEY --
$250,000 FOR 20%
WITH A DISTINCT DIRECTION
IN LICENSING.
WHAT HAVE YOU DECIDED TO DO?
ROBERT, IF YOU WOULD DO
15% FOR $150,000...
SO, YOU'RE COUNTERING ROBERT?
AND YOU'RE NOT INTERESTED
IN DAYMOND'S OFFER.
HOLD ON.
IS THAT CORRECT?
WELL, NO, NO.
WELL, ARE YOU?
SO, WE'RE GONNA GO --
I THINK WE WOULD LIKE...
WELL, IDEALLY,
WE WOULD WANT TO HAVE A --
IT WOULD -- IT WOULD BE NICE
TO HAVE A DEAL
BETWEEN ALL OF THE SHARKS.
UH, YOU KNOW, ONE THING
ABOUT BEING IN THE TANK IS,
I LOVE PEOPLE
TO BE DECISIVE.
SO, I'M OUT.
SO, NOW IT'S ON YOU, ROB.
I'M GONNA STICK AT THE 20%.
MARK, DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING
TO ADD?
I THINK
W-WHAT YOUR CHALLENGE IS --
AND YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD THIS
YOUR ENTIRE LIVES --
IS YOU'RE BOTH
VERY DELIBERATE.
NO, THEY'RE NOT.
THEY CAN'T MAKE A DECISION.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
BUT THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM,
RIGHT?
SOMETIMES, THE PERF--
THE PERFECT IS THE ENEMY
OF THE GOOD, RIGHT?
PARALYSIS VIA ANALYSIS.
AND THAT'S WHY I WAS LISTENING.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS TRYING
TO GET A SENSE OF
'CAUSE I LIKE THE PRODUCT,
BUT YOU GUYS DON'T HAVE
A FORCEFUL WAY TO GET THERE.
AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT YOU COULD REALLY ACCEPT
A FORCEFUL WAY
TO GET THERE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
I WAS THE FIRST GUY
TO MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I THOUGHT I MADE YOU
A FAIR OFFER.
THEN YOU LISTENED
TO DAYMOND'S OFFER,
WHICH IS VERY RESPECTFUL,
AND AT THE VERY END OF IT ALL,
I REITERATED MY OFFER,
TYLER LOOKED AT ME
FOR A MOMENT
AND THEN LOOKED OVER
AT MARK.
WE'RE DEFINITELY INTERESTED
IN YOUR OFFER, BUT --
I'M OUT.
I TOLD YOU NASTY THINGS CAN
HAPPEN WHEN YOU LEAVE THE TANK.
SO, TO -- I GUESS THE REASON
TO EXPLAIN WHY WE --
WE DON'T NEED TO KNOW.
YOU GOT --
YOU HAVE NOBODY LEFT.
WHY WE WANTED TO WAIT
TO SEE...
WE'RE GOOD. THAT'S IT.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE EXAMPLE
OF TWO ENTREPRENEURS
THAT WERE INCAPABLE
OF MAKING A DECISION.
LEI, YOU KNOW WHY --
IT'S NOT THAT WE'RE INCAPABLE
OF MAKING A DECISION.
LEI, IT DOESN'T --
NO, LOOK,
YOU CAN'T MAKE A DECISION.
THERE'S NOBODY LEFT.
WE CAN'T DO THAT
ON $150,000 --
I FORBID YOU
TO SPEAK ANYMORE.
NO, WE --
YOU KNOW, WE GET THAT.
PLEASE LEAVE.
$150,000, GONE.
$250,000, VAPORIZED.
NOW YOU'RE VAPORIZED.
GET OUT OF HERE.
BUT -- BUT --
NO BUTS.
BUT NOW
THAT WE UNDERSTAND...
GONE. GONE.
BYE. YOU GUYS GOT TO GO.
SORRY.
...WHERE THE SHARKS
STAND --
WOULD -- WOULD IT
BE POSSIBLE FOR US...
Cuban: GOOD LUCK. BYE.
GUYS, IT'S TOO LATE.
...TO ACCEPT YOUR OFFER?
LET SOMEONE ELSE
HAVE A CHANCE.
LIFE DOESN'T WORK
THAT WAY.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
WELL, SHOULD HAVE GONE
WITH DAYMOND.
TOLD YOU.
INCREDIBLE.
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
NOW, THAT WAS
THE FIRST DATE.
IMAGINE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
AFTER THAT.
I GUARANTEE YOU
THIS HAPPENS TO THEM
EVERY DAY OF THEIR LIVES.
I CAN IMAGINE THEM
TRYING TO PICK OUT LUNCH.
WHY ARE YOU STILL TALKING
ABOUT THEM? THEY'RE GONE!
THEY'RE DEAD.
THEY'RE GONE.